life imitated art when Paul Hogan fell
for his Crocodile Dundee love interest
there was just one roadblock his wife of
30 years
Paul Hogan told the BBC that a trip to
New York inspired Crocodile Dundee's
Fish Out of Water tail saying I felt
like an alien from another planet some
of the bushy guys I know would feel even
more out of place there's a myth that
there is a real Crocodile Dundee but
there isn't still many believe Rod
ansel's 1977 Survival Story was the
inspiration for the character Mick
Dundee Ansel became famous in Australia
after surviving for seven weeks
unlimited supplies in the wilderness
after his boat was capsized in the
Northern Territory indigenous Aborigines
ultimately rescued Ansel but when people
learned that he survived off the land
and even resorted to drinking Buffalo
blood his unlikely Survival Story
fascinated them television host Michael
Parkinson interviewed Ansel who told
viewers he slept on the floor at the
luxury hotel in Sydney just like mcdundy
later did in the movie In 1980 Ansel
published his story in the book to fight
the wild but Hogan never admitted that
Ansel was his inspiration after
Crocodile Dundee he became a hit Ansel
grew bitter because he never earned
royalties from the film according to the
herald sun in 1999 Ansel died after
ambushing police in a drug-fueled
shootout that left one police officer
dead and other civilians injured
the financing group that funded
Crocodile Dundee was the brainchild of
Hogan's business partner John Cornell
who envisioned an inventive model to
finance the independent comedy they
actually chose to not partner with the
Australian film Commission because they
wanted full creative control over the
project instead a Queensland Bank
underwrote the 7.1 million dollars of
the film's budget while Cornell found
additional funding from 1400 small
investors including Michael Hutchins the
lead singer of the Australian band in
excess after they completed the film
Cornell flew to the U.S to look for a
distributor according to the New York
Times Paramount snapped up the U.S
distribution rights of Crocodile Dundee
when 20th Century Fox turned Cornell
down after watching only 20 minutes of
the movie after the first and second
Crocodile Dundee movies were huge
commercial hits Cornell told the New
York Times that the fox executive had
been extremely rude I sometimes get
pleasure from thinking about what the
look is like on his face at a time like
this
the first scene in Crocodile Dundee has
a big Easter egg referencing Paul
Hogan's life before acting it happens
when we see the Sydney Harbor Bridge in
the background while Sue Tarleton talks
to her boyfriend on the phone at the
beginning of the film according to the
Canberra times before he got his break
in Showbiz on the talent show new faces
Hogan worked as a rigger on the iconic
Bridge he told IGN that he did the show
on a dare and won over the Audience by
roasting the judges
I went on new faces to take the Mickey
out of it one of the few people that
ever went on a talent Quest and had no
intention or desire to Win It after
appearing on new faces Hogan was
interviewed at the Sydney Harbor Bridge
for the show a current affair which
brought him to the attention of future
business and creative partner John
Cornell Cornell and Hogan started JP
Productions and the Paul Hogan show made
Hogan famous first in Australia and a
leader in the U.S after the sketch
series became syndicated internationally
Hogan then became in the face of
Australian tourism with an advertisement
inviting Americans to visit the Wonders
Down Under This would later set the
stage for the success of Crocodile
Dundee in America
Crocodile Dundee was shot on location in
Australia and New York City production
for the Outback scenes was filmed in the
isolated kakadu National Park in the
Northern Territory which had been home
to a uranium mine Craig Bowles the
Australian location scout for Crocodile
Dundee selected the isolated region
because as he explained it showcased a
part of Australia that I don't think had
been seen and it was inherent in Paul's
nature he seemed to fit into the
landscape perfectly although kakadu
national park has since become a popular
tourist destination Bulls explained
kakadu was a very different place in the
1980s to what it is today only the main
road was paved and there were no Hotel
facilities at all as far as I can
remember because they were so far from
hotels everyone on the cast and crew
slept in Huts left behind by the Penn
Continental Mining Company despite the
dilapidated condition of the camp the
cast and crew made the best of it
spending their nights around a campfire
and creating a summer camp atmosphere
after test screenings with American
audiences Paramount trimmed seven
minutes from the movie to make an
international cut Barry London president
of distribution at Paramount told the
New York Times that they had to Quicken
the pace to suit us viewers most of the
cut screen time came from the first half
of the film where Mick Dundee is showing
Sue Tarleton around the Australian
Outback during the test screenings
American audiences also struggled to
understand the Australian slang in the
film so much of that was cut as well
additionally the f word was dropped from
the movie so it could have a PG-13
rating in the U.S Paramount added
quotation marks around crocodile on the
posters and the title card so everyone
would understand it was a man's nickname
and not a movie about a crocodile Paul
Hogan had planned on using a real
crocodile for close-ups during the scene
where Sue was attacked this simply
wasn't in the cards so production
purchased a mechanical crocodile for 45
000 although the crocodile that attacked
Sue while she's quilling off in the
water was animatronic there were real
crocodiles all over the set they hired
an armed guard and crocodile Wrangler to
protect the production from Croc
interference as Hogan explained to go
Eerie while promoting the very excellent
Mr Dundee in 2021 we had guys up trees
with rifles just in case one came along
and ruined everything
Hogan told IGN that the water buffalo
was the real stubborn Diva on set during
the interview he explained that the
scene where he mesmerizes the Buffalo
took all day adding because if the
Buffalo doesn't want to do anything it
weighs 2 000 pounds and you know it
doesn't Paul Hogan met his first wife
nolene Edwards when they were teenagers
at the swimming pool where he was the
Lifeguard and they married young in
1958. Hogan told Australian story I had
three sons by the time I was 22 so I had
to grow up very fast although Paul Hogan
was still married to Edwards while
making Crocodile Dundee he ultimately
left his first wife for his co-star
Linda Kozlowski Hogan and Edwards had a
very public and ugly second divorce in
1989 with Australian media Outlets
reportedly depicting him as abandoning
his family
plus I've got five children to think
about and they were just as heard as I
was but in a different way Hogan married
Kozlowski in 1990 in Australia during a
private ceremony at a mansion he built
as a wedding gift to his bride they had
a son named Chase and settled in Los
Angeles but eventually divorced in 2014.
Kozlowski told new idea honestly we just
naturally grew apart the divorce was
completely amicable everybody's happy
Crocodile Dundee hit Australian Cinemas
on April 24 1986. Hogan predicted it
would be a commercial success telling
Cinema papers I expected to gross
millions of dollars around the world and
I'm planning for it to be Australia's
first proper movie Hogan was right
arriving in the U.S in September
Crocodile Dundee was one of the highest
grossing films of 1986 and was only
beaten at the U.S box office by Top Gun
it remains to this day the highest
grossing Australian film at the
Australian box office the film's success
came with a downside unrealistic
expectations in 2022 Hogan told Mark
meets because of the ridiculous success
of Dundee which is still the most
successful independent film ever made
it's sort of like oh whatever I do next
will be a flop by comparison so why
bother so mentally I sort of retired
after the first one
us audiences were already familiar with
Paul Hogan before Crocodile Dundee came
out because of the Australian tourism
advertisements he donated his time to
during the 80s you say Estrada is the
world's biggest island and as you can
appreciate the accent varies noticeably
from one place to another
when Crocodile Dundee became an
international success it altered tourism
in Australia in 2016 tourism Chief
Executive Tony male told Perth now the
film helped put Australia on the map
according to the guardian they even
started giving Crocodile Dundee tours in
kakadu National Park where the movie was
filmed and in Darwin where you can have
close encounters with live crocodiles
three hours away in jabaru you can stay
in the Indigenous owned kakadu crocodile
hotel which is shaped like a crocodile
from there you can explore the
Wilderness of kakadu through guided
tours Scenic flights or arts and crafts
lessons with indigenous Aboriginal
tribes who have lived in the Northern
Territory for at least 40 000 years
the film's sequel Crocodile Dundee 2 was
a top 5 box office hit in 1988 but after
that the franchise seemed dead then in
2001 Crocodile Dundee in Los Angeles
came out and proved without a doubt that
it was nominated in 2002 for the Razzie
for worst sequel or remake and sitting
at 11 on Rotten Tomatoes Crocodile
Dundee in Los Angeles was a box office
disappointment and a critical disaster
the film's production was troubled as
well according to den of geek there was
a dispute over the script between
screenwriting Duo Matthew Berry and Eric
Abrams and Hogan Hogan extensively
rewrote their screenplay and believed he
should receive the writing credit
ultimately The Writer's Guild sided with
the original scriptwriters they gave
Barry and Abrams credit despite Hogan
appealing the decision Hogan told the
Los Angeles Times anyone who ever saw
the first two movies will know who wrote
whatever comes out of anyone's mouth but
because I didn't change the plot and I
am the producer I was not credited as a
writer in January 2018 teasers began
dropping on the internet for what seemed
to be a Crocodile Dundee reboot starring
Danny McBride as Mick Dundee's son it
was followed by a full trailer and a
Super Bowl ad you know when your dad did
it he was he was okay and well my dad
told me about this he was just like yeah
I just came up and they they did this
but it was soon revealed to be a 27
million dollar ad campaign to revitalize
Australian tourism McBride told Insider
it wasn't like I was looking to do a
Super Bowl commercial but I just thought
the concept of this was just too funny
to see what people's reaction would be
like Australia's Minister for trade
tourism and investment Stephen chobo
told Tourism Australia this is the
single largest investment Tourism
Australia has ever made in the U.S
market and one we believe will grow
annual spend by American visitors to 6
billion Australian by the year 2020.
fans hoping for an actual Revival had
their hopes dashed though when Hogan
told today it's not gonna happen
in 2020 Paul Hogan starred in the very
excellent Mr Dundee a satire where he
played a fictionalized version of
himself the movie depicts him getting
into hot water on social media and
meeting a bunch of other old comedy
Stars Hogan told Boomer Magazine it's
not a deep meaningful movie just a bit
of fun while it pokes fun at Hollywood
rules and how social media through the
modern online community can give you a
reputation that you don't deserve it's
mostly aimed at me Hogan making himself
the butt of the joke is certainly
familiar ground for the Aussie whose
self-deprecating humor won audiences
back in the 70s and 80s though critics
panned the very excellent Mr Dundee
giving it abysmal scores on Rotten
Tomatoes in 2020 Hogan also released his
Memoir the tap dancing knife thrower my
life without the boring bits Hogan told
go Eerie that it was the brainchild of
his longtime writing partner Dean Murphy
it was Dean again who talked me into
doing the book telling me that if I
dictated it he'd write it down so that
appealed to my lazy side Hogan might be
done with Hollywood but that doesn't
mean audiences have gotten him or that
iconic role from the land down under
[Music]